haquin qu'on va changer le mode de
scrutin au québec récemment avec le
mécontentement suscitées par la réforme
de la carte électorale beaucoup en ont
profité pour dénoncer le mode de scrutin
au québec c'est que bien souvent après
une élection le poids d'un parti
politique à l'assemblée nationale n'est
pas du tout représentatif du pourcentage
des votes remporté à preuve le parti
libéral du québec a gagné la majorité 70
des 125 sièges en 2014 avec seulement 42
% des votes sans raison du mode de
scrutin majoritaire uninominal à un tour
mais beaucoup crient à l'injustice et
milite pour un mode de scrutin
proportionnel mixte compensatoire plus
représentatif comme en allemagne
monsieur mascotte vous avez consacré une
grande partie de votre carrière au mode
de scrutin
est-ce que vous avez abandonné l'idée de
voir se produire si le passé est garant
de l'avenir
je serais très surpris des députés
ministériels ne sont pas des
marionnettes
ils sont des acteurs actifs ils sont
conscients que changement du système
électoral
or des infos sur leurs perspectives de
carrière
voici la chambre après l'élection de
2014 et voici un scénario avec un mode
mixte
regardez bien ici les petits partis la
cac et québec solidaire gagne des sièges
au détriment des libéraux donc il peut y
avoir une volonté du chef de parti du
premier ministre
chloé mais c'est la députation ou en
tout cas des députés qui n'ont pas de
perdre leur job piano puis les vagues
acier de rédiger deux fois et vous savez
que c'était des échecs sous monsieur
charest ou salaisons pas été capable non
plus de le réaliser c'est un élément
fondamental pour rebâtir le lien de
confiance est elle pas en accord pour
qu'il y ait davantage de minorités
ethnoculturelles qu'ils soient
représentés à l'assemblée davantage de
jeunes que les régions soient me
représenter les québécois préfèrent la
stabilité
ce sont les québécois qui préfèrent la
stabilité ou
participation pour aem certainement
mieux la stabilité ce qu'ils aiment
surtout c'est le pouvoir sans partage
ce qui est instable c'est la situation
que nous avons lorsque nos gouvernements
sont minoritaires
ils ne sont pas capables d'accepter ce
qui serait la solution de partager le
pouvoir pour une longue période de
quatre heures les gouvernements seraient
à l'avenir formés de coalitions de
partis donc l'entente culture cependant
l'europe
et voilà vous avez le terme c'est pas
dans nos habitudes postuler que parce
qu'on aura la proportionnelle les
gouvernements changeront à tous les ans
ou tous les deux ans
c'est certainement pas très bien
connaître l'expérience de certains pays
la plupart a fait deux pays qui
n'utilisent
[Musique]